hi everyone my name is Sam and I'm a
graduate student in comparative Media
Studies I have a background in animation
and public health research and I'm
fascinated by people who can take big
complex history topics and offer them up
for discussion and artistic formats so
I'm really excited to be speaking with
Rosa today for a cast conversation and
love to give her a chance for a self
introduction hey Rosa
and I am an illustrator comic artist
from Puerto Rico I live in someone and
I've been self-publishing comics for ten
years and recently I've switched over to
political comics where I I tried to
write a comic about our experiences in
the island or politics and all the
problems that have surfaced after
Hurricane Maria specifically and I
usually published mostly on the NAMM
book but I've also been published on the
believer and the lily for The Washington
Post so my first question sort of brings
us here today is pretty basic but what
brought you to MIT and how is it
influencing your work well I was invited
by cast and mikail Jacobson to work for
the MIT game lab on illustrations for a
board game based on promise that the
promesa law in Puerto Rico so the
promise a law is a law that President
Obama signed a way back in 2016 and it
imposes a fiscal oversight and control
board over our government and it's been
a huge of course it's been a huge issue
here and I wrote a little bit about it
on my comics and so Michael contacted me
based on that because they need they
wanted somebody who was native to the
problem and to the country to do the
illustrations for this board game
oh I'm also interested in sort of this
shift from some of the more 2d static
artistic formats that you said you're
kind of you're rooted in and how the
interactivity and the collaboration of
this project effects your approach to
covering the topic well it's been really
interesting be never worked on a game
game but a game board before and I
sometimes I hardly even play them even
so it was very interesting to figure out
how to tell a story I could not tell
right now if it's just my okay it looks
like Rosa is frozen it's not just me so
well I think we wait for Rosa to join us
I think I can use this time to sort of
set up the next learn a question that I
have basically I had the wonderful
opportunity to play test the program
it's a board game that the game lab is
working on and then Rosa is contributing
to and the design of it to me is just
really fascinating it takes this complex
story of the law that Nosa was just
describing and puts you in the position
maybe generally the Berto Rican
government trying to make balances
between spending money on infrastructure
and education and paying off its debt to
the US and the debt it's sort of in the
form of these physical jewels that
you're trying to push off of the map but
in order to do that you also need to
spend some of those jewels education
infrastructure Rosa's Beck it's crazy
here yeah I fixed it so hopefully hope
won't happen again all right I was
talking a little bit about my experience
play testing the game or just the way
that it kind of works I think we can
circle back to some of the experience
with the medium as a part of this
question but I was essentially sort of
talking about how one thing that stuck
out to me about this game was how really
closely tied the topic and the the
format are compared to other games that
I've had the chance to test out with the
game lab in their anti-colonial board
game project sort of playing other board
games that approach this topic one thing
that stuck out to me about a lot of
those games is that the colonialist
themes usually have nothing to do with
actual gameplay or the interactions and
rather than make some sort of
educational or aesthetic or emotional
statement about colonialism those games
usually just use the theme as an excuse
to have fun while collecting treasure
and so it was really refreshing for me
to see this board game dive into the
tricky questions of how to educate and
offer a meaningful aesthetic experience
and highlight the emotional experience
of balancing infrastructure and
education and debt at that government
level and so my next question is related
did that and tributing your artwork to
this game I really want to know what
it's like to try to do all those things
at once and have the artwork also help
people learn how to play the game and so
I know you got cut off a little bit and
sort of explaining the how the format
affect to you but I think this can sort
of all be rolled up into one big
question yeah I mean McHale didn't
explain to me how the game was before I
got MIT for the for the quick visit and
I think he was right because you have to
actually experience it because it's uh I
was also kind of expecting it to be like
well I'm gonna educate you about this
and you're gonna roll the dice and
you're gonna get to from point A to
point B and that's it
but I think what they created is very
creative because it puts the person in
the position of having to actually
analyze on how to spend the resources of
a whole country but in a very simple way
so one of my challenges is how to
contextualize that so it's even more
obvious so that when the game asks you
to invest in an infrastructure then
we'll what specific example of Puerto
Rico's history can I use there so that
the person can engage with history as
well as engaged with the game and
because I do comics I'm very used to
I'll walk you through the story but now
the people actually have to like play
the game and it's very cooperative to
like you like you notice so what I think
my challenge is is how to present Porto
Rico in a non stereotypical way how to
contextualize the history so that the
person understands how to play it but at
the same time learn something about how
well if we put the resources from
education to infrastructure and you lose
this and this is going to happen it
could end up in a protest it could end
up with a teacher strike but also one of
the things that I'm very excited to work
on with this project is that make I also
wanted a comic book as the instructions
mmm but then the the comic book is not
only just going to be the instructions
on how to play it'll be a conversation
between two players about the context of
the history of the game so I'm very
excited to to be able to put something
that I'm very comfortable with into the
game at the same time while being
challenged with all of the illustrations
and and kind of like the decisions of
what I want to illustrate there so that
the person takes something away from the
game more than the enjoyment of playing
oh and I think that leads me into my
final question of there's a lot to
unpack in this game I think it'll mean a
lot depending on who plays it in what
context and when even and so my last
question to use
is who do you want to play this game I
want everybody to play the games but I
know that everybody here is super
excited the the moment I said that I was
working on four game about put paprika
people were like but what is it about
what I need to know I do have a
prototype and they were so excited so I
would I would really I would really love
to have once everything is done to a
point I would really love to have a
community after the pandemic after
everything a community plays so that
people here can add to their add their
own stories to the game and and maybe
start like I think this game can can
probably have a type of closure or
healing on some of the of these topics
like oh yeah like they could go oh I
remember when we protested about this or
I remember how I felt when the
government announced this and that but
that they are also working together and
realize that oh yeah if we do invest in
education we might have a way out so it
sounds like a bit of a grim game saying
like oh this is just to push the dead
off the island and the dead is so huge
that it's unpayable and you're gonna
learn that but I think because it's
cooperative it has it has a way to maybe
help form a conversation so that people
can get a little bit of closure and a
little bit of recontextualization on
their feelings and of their history I'm
very excited to play here yeah I'm
excited to play the the final game as
well great thanks so much this was a
really fantastic conversation it was
really inspiring to learn more about
your own approach to this work how the
dialogue around the project and you know
exposure to some of the issues that
you're talking about getting that into
MIT and making that part of the the
conversation around here something that
I really appreciated seeing so thank you
so much and thanks for the thank
everybody for letting me work on this
project
thank you Sam and Rosa and thanks
everyone for joining us for this
conversation please visit art
mit.edu slash from anywhere for a wide
range of arts activities online
exhibitions and performances research
and more also keep an eye on our website
for more information about this board
game and the developments in the future
thanks again everyone and have a
wonderful weekend goodbye